Tại sao nay ngày 18,5 năm, tại sinh chạm dừng gì kêu mết bộ miếm mốt
có tốt thỉnh bố chiming lòng thành giấu dưới sế giá vụ tên an giá thông đặc biệt nghiêm chọt khiến
những người thương vòng.
Thông tin bà đầu khoảng hôm dường mề bộ phút cùng ngày, ô tốt thứ hơn,
chưa gió bình kiểm soát, người điều khiến, lưu thông theo hủy lòng thành giấu dây,
sát xun quý, tình đồng ngày.
Khi đến liện điểm triển khi đâm vào đứa xe đầu kéo mang biệt nghiêm xuất hả tiến,
gió tại xí khác, sinh 1 miếm trị trăm tà môi, chú tại hả tiến, được khiến đang đủ tại giống lỗi thời trạm dừng gì.
Họ qua xe thú thương bốc trái, xin xe khó năm người, ôm, ông về vê hát, sinh 1 miếm trị trăm năm người,
chú tại ra lai, bà nửa tế tế hát, sinh 1 miếm trị trăm bệm biệt nghiêm nhạc biệt nghiêm.
Bà nửa tế lựa, sinh 1 miếm trị trăm sống biệt nghiêm, ông về vê nửa và tệ xe xe khu thương.
Ông hát, bà hát ký thử xe, đứa đi cấp hữu, bà người còn lại mất kể xe xe, tự vong.
Mình như ngu tên đặc đặc đục đu trà làm sống.